guarda tutti ragazzi e prendi tutto che
sono video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
tornati su the forest dopo non so quanto
tempo tra l'altro bene sempre belle le
mani tozze bambi bambi la state vedendo
anche non giunto bambi per caso da
l'ultima patch trend della roba così
almeno non muoio devo andare dove cazzo
andata ma ho già visto bambi e
impossibile cos'è ha già il contapassi
giusto non perché quando chiediamo su
un'isola noi ci dobbiamo contare i passi
grazie molto gentile ti metti un calzino
per cortesia abbiamo una missione già
devo capire perché i piccioni entrano
nelle cose
[Musica]
hanno aggiunto delle degli animali
quelli due si stanno ingrossando ragazzi
prima di ma ciao
ma quanto sei bella vieni miei vieni
vieni dopo ave gente
a [ __ ] beh va beh termina fermi un
attimo zio ascoltami cazzo ti trapassi
ce la fate a stare fermi natale ascolta
visione medie cdc per cortesia niente la
madre rosica gli alberi io non so che
cosa hanno aggiunto di nuovo perché non
gioca ragazzi al suo gioco da troppo non
gioca la sua gioco non fa ridere perché
i ragazzi dei lotti non ci crederò mai
ma veramente sono morto così c'è
rendetevi conto ragazzi sono salve
sei per caso tu
britney spears e ti regalo per caso una
valigia di mitongu non è che mi fai ti
può scappare non c'ha il bene è una cosa
la ragazzina io vado via di qua cosa
qualche [ __ ]
tua mamma sfrutta anche la tua ma tu sei
più brutto è il survivor 0 fantastico
sono riuscito a morire due volte
nell'arco di un minuto e mezzo c'è
veramente ridicolo medico è tutta colpa
del tuo piede di merda solo perché puzza
e gli facciamo tutto la fate finta che
non sia successo niente ok un gazebo ma
se sé ma davvero ragazzi prossimo
obiettivo costruire un gazebo non lo
faccio quando farò più avanti mi sono
comparsi dei si muovono dei tavoli non
riuscirò a mangiare mai per il resto
della mia vita perché salve lui ha
lanciato il tavolo gli è caduto in testa
nel morto così cruda go giorno anche a
lei scusi se l'ho ammazzato una
lucertola davanti gradisce perché sei
morto lanciando un tavolo me lo devi
spiegare con quel momento ci fai con un
bengala perché ho una testa di un uomo
essere o non essere
io ho una testa devo trovare un posto
decente dove fare un gazebo lo troviamo
ma salve ma che cosa diavolo saresti tu
ma che bello che se ma vedo che gradisce
anche bene il mcdonald's enti ascolta
zio ti dispiace se per caso tra ancora
ce ne sono bambi non guardare bambi non
guardare
salve ecco ragazzi perché ed ecco
ragazzi perché stare tanto al telefono
fa male compra apple compra
da samsung galaxy s 5 io adoro sta cosa
bambi ascoltami tieni sa testa bambini
ma mi sveglia bambini mamme babbi e non
vuole io giuro donna dalle tette
diversamente piccole che cosa che vuoi
di preciso scappate via perché ucciso
bambini ucciso ma eccoti mammi perfetto
ascolta ascolta milk tra un paio non
posso tralasciare gli alberi non solo se
come the ok ok niente lei attraversa gli
alberi brava così stronza di merda che
va a dirlo proprio il capo datemi i
narco york jo squillo stores questo io
vinco perché ho scoperto visto l'acqua
scritto pistola acqua no no cazzo ho
detto pistola ascoltami si va bene
vogliamo metterci un po di più quieto
fus ha visto l'acqua adesso adesso
adesso
vabbè dai uso fuga ma tanto io nel
gazebo ci invito solo bambino voi perché
siete brutti inoltre non sono ammesse
donne senza reggiseno nel mio gazebo
talaltro cos'è giunga un campo
se mi alzo in piedi passo attraverso la
tenda fantastico alla ragazza morì al
sistema ragazzi sulla spiaggia la gara
era mio obiettivo adesso che non c'è
nessuna teatro en aggiunto non c'erano
quelle tende una volta l'anno aggiunte
sono nuove fantastico perfette ragazze
che sia mi dispiace abbiamo le nostre
belle copertine l'auto sembra che sto
mangiando una nasconde in realtà c'è una
testa di qualcuno in mano ragazzi cè un
gabbiano santa fermina timo poiché cazzo
di borsa gli ho dato
[Musica]
e ora di fare il gazebo perché se non lo
facciamo più tanto io lo faccio in un
invito a nessuno tranne i bambi proprio
che mi sta simpatica facciamo facciamolo
dove c'è ecco perfetto sembra che
abbiano fantastico no no no no no no mi
servi servi
la tela lancio davo bravo zio torna qui
bravo
ecco che ascoltano perché c'è un paura
ecco come è morto oddio è superman non è
un nido dove potete cagare e il mio
gazebo ok allora è così
la partenza è fantastica vediamo di
riuscire madonna 21 tronchi contate erg
ha regalato onlus cosa gol un qua
il mio testo per matrix diga dicendo al
caldo ecco allora se la donna con le
tette
anzi no se senza tette ferma un attimo
cosa ti urli cosa no no da ragazzi sto
morendo non se ne ammazza m'incazzo
[ __ ] troppo mio addio svenuta mica l'ho
colpita con una testa non è che ho fatto
chissà cosa
la tv al gol mi mancava era che non
avevano ancora l'aveva incontrata come
questo fa sì che cazzo è mi chiamo devo
cuocere un burla ecco questo questo
fuoco come si deve mi saranno d'ora
metti non ci arriverò mai perché c'è gol
perché stai cosa fai
no è troppo bello essere tornato a
giocare a the forest mi mancava troppo
diciamo queste stranezze
ok perfetto diamoci foca sta roba perché
c'è uno zombie che si sta avvicinando
pianissimo alla mia posizione sia esatto
quello lo sta indica allora ci sono due
zombie e tu che cosa fai prendi un
piccione sul dito ti sembra normale ma
quanto c'è in sopposto reagan da prima
non c'era nessuno non è possibile
scommettete che sono talmente [ __ ]
da passare sul fuoco ma ci scommetto
guardano lo sapevo se avrei scommesso
già vescovo per festeggiare prende un
piccione
evitiamo di stare davanti da mi è mai
mancato ne mancato brava sia brava skott
ahn dispiace se ti uccido no perché sei
brutta non è morta forse adesso è morta
ragazzi le molotov sono il suo gioco se
non hai le molotov non fai un metro che
cosa fanno
ascolta su quello è il mio grazie stanno
stuprando un morto ma non solo stanno
mangiando il mortal ascoltami fiocco
cielo con questo ok bravo media gli ho
dato fuoco di cosa corri to corso
accordi che ti prendo schiaffo soccorsi
bocciato ecco gioca male morte e adesso
è morto anche lui cioè fatemi capire
perché se non sa perché ci aveva il bel
culetto è se non la mangiavate sta tizia
cosa cosa cosa cazzo ha fatto
[Musica]
non ascolta cos'è sta roba bruttissimo
ma il cicciobello non li vendono più se
è una strada di sopra però mio non ce la
farò mai riuscire sono già lo so io lo
so io ci muoio qua dentro sono
convintissimo giorno sono fi
dormi dormi dormi picchio finché non hai
neanche il pene non ti vergogni butta e
sai fermo bravo
stavo scherzando piazzavo ti ammazzo
pura tempo da marzo a tutti quanti
ammazzo faccio una strage dai regala non
vedo un cazzo ma tornare per favore
tutti i cani che cos'è o di un casco ha
trovato un casco della madonna madonna
ho trovato un po un mio zio
oh mio dio un bambino mezzo un albero
che ho visto una cosa troppo [ __ ] le le
anatre che fingono gen no va bene sa
cosa è una figata voglio un'anatra
adesso ovviamente regalo io non mi
allora non so che cosa c'è dentro questi
container mi fa piacere che ci sia
qualcuno da averli notati prima di me ci
fosse meno che tu non sia rimasto
schiacciato dai container come dal
tavolo zio però con e mi escono i
pinguini l'astrologo tipo in madagascar
quale la nave da carico che ha perso sta
roba dato trasportavano cose fantastiche
tipo una bottiglia piena discarica
stoppa cos'è sta roba al centro amazon
lasciamo perdere che a container pacchi
fantastico facciamo farvi risponde
adesso lo dicevo ragazzi ci ha messo due
ore per tornare qua prova bene va ne è
valsa la pena almeno perché come posto
gli altri poi faceva anche a gare come
posti e io devo tagliare legna come se
niente fosse proprio tanto mi servono 60
tronchi già farò mai
abbiate pazienza ancora quelli di
baywatch
la band
hanno state mangiando scusatemi
richiamato anch'io a fare il pranzo per
questo sto messo abbastanza male di cibo
quindi pranziamo tutti tranquilli se
riescano ammazzarli tutti un promessa
che mi devo preparare un po di molotov
giusto infatti raccogliere la legna come
cristo comanda per favore prima che
possibilmente non sulla mia come non
detto
salve portami e mi dai una mano con i
tronchi visto che ce ne sono tanti la
portarmi dai una mano
no è bravo bravo prof e prendi o premio
eseguiti vieni qui vieni qua a porta
ecco però porta della gente perché da
solo non ce la faccio dobbiamo uscire a
fare sto cazzo di gazebo da noi
pago ti pago in denti se voglio in donne
con poche tette perfetto è la madonna
cosa sono ultimi è una cosa oggi è il
fanta bello rega bellissimo mi servono
21 fottuti tronti percorso di un gazebo
madonna manco lo comprasse all'ikea
va bene va bene dai parte va bene dai
party hard facciamo così dire se non ti
offre una discoteca visto che era
durante qua di notte
metto luci stroboscopiche e ci siamo
anche anche aperte piccioni è un ramo
uno sì ma mi state prendendo per il culo
porro finché non trova un tronco poi
torni indietro e dormo prima che mi
prendono non ce la farò mai
lo so che lo sciopero mai non so che
sono fare ho preso l'ho preso preso
preso bastano mi toccate non mi toccate
intoccate lo rivelano rifugio no no no
no no non ho tanta dai montanti denunciò
ti denuncio bravo dove sto andargli
canoa
no no no tu donna brutta via
si no non ci credo non ci credo non ci
credo non ci credo
grazie era a salve bello belli grazie
grazie
i velisti capelli tu non ce l'hai tolta
fratello non è che se scendo mi su cd
vero no bravo ascolta e prendiamo questo
pia kiko cose come ha fatto un
paracadutista paracadutarsi qua ma sei
ormando ma che scusa no questo è morto
regala non si muove beh meglio così è
non è che mi interessava vederlo
muoversi
usciamo da sto schifo sì esatto nel
circuito cosa avete un computer mercato
ma chiamando un messaggio è stat
rimaniamo incastrati nelle caverne
ragazzi se riesco ad uscire alla
selezione uscire poi basta
il gazebo lo faccio poi perché non ce la
posso più fare per te cos'è zio l'hai
visto anche tu non hai visto tu non
l'hai visto non è visto non l'hai visto
hai visto non sente ma mi ha preso
perché lui la mattina mattina si alza e
fa jogging come tutti dovrebbero fare lo
schiacciava che il salo madonna che
brutto che sei ecco ecco bravo fuori tua
sorella pure ecco perfetta ma cosa
strisci cosa cazzo striscia t'ammazzo la
famiglia davo mari ma non muore non c'è
verso cioè oporto amica dopo mezz'ora
ragazzi i temi che posso si madonna la
torre e gli faccio una pippa adesso ne
ho trovato c'è l'uscita ragazzi si si
gesù santos e si è scoppiato giorno a
caso ho trovato un martello della
madonna e poi sono riuscito ad uscire
non fatemi domande non voglio neanche
sapere come abbiamo dovuto cary stonare
in croato per riuscire a fare sta roba
e c'è ancora gente nella mia spiaggia
allora zio questa è la mia spiaggia la
veglia scritta vietato nudisti l'ho
messa io quindi ti levi da il cazzo
bravo e questo è quello che fanno i
nudisti perché il gazebo chi è capito il
gazebo che non è fia non è finito mi che
mi sembra finito
ricapitolando ragazzi ho passato una
nottata di
guarda perché voi non lo sapete ma
quando voi andate a dormire tutti quando
dormite che di addormentate questa sera
pensate forte forte al vostro fa vj ozil
vi si salva perché io sono sempre nella
merda di notte sicuro mai no cos'è conto
o giusto rumore bruttissimo cosa
stupisce to fail
ascoltami superman
niente affatto vabbé vabbé live
affanculo tutti nudi
ok perfetto ragazzi siamo quasi arrivati
alla fine va basta però non ce la posso
più fare continuo nel prossimo episodio
lega perché sono messi ma fatemi dormire
che almeno c'è salvo ecco perfetto può
salvare o salvato o fatta se continuo
dal prossimo lega pro che si sta
mettendo male comunque i ragazzi
concluso pieno episodio la farei
concluderà voi due ebbero dico però non
ci avete il telecomando quindi cucchiaia
si sa il video è piaciuto come al solito
lascia documento mi piace al capace di
facebook e come negli video tratta una
descrizione certo in questi undici metri
ci mettiamo un prossimo video belle
ragazze